well security has always been a hugely
contentious issue for Prince Harry ever
since he left his role as a senior
working role he's not entitled to
security or automatic police protection
when he or his family are in the UK he
was challenging that decision and this
case was in particular about the
decision not to let him pay for his own
protection now Harry's lawyers had
argued that this question about whether
or not he could pay for it had not been
taken correctly he said that it had been
taken by ravik which is this executive
committee for the protection of royalty
and VIP that it should have been taken
his lawyers claimed by the home office
instead they'd argued that under the
police Act of 1996 there was provision
for private individuals to be able to
pay for their own policing however when
this preliminary hearing was heard at
the high court the Met Office made it
very clear they thought this would be
unjust that you should have wealthy
individuals able to pay for their own
police saying that it was not a fair
decision not a fair situation and it
wasn't right that the Richer people
richer people should be able to play for
policing this way Harry has lost this
appeal this he was wanting a judicial
review Into the decision he has lost
that bid today this is just one of a
couple of cases he has about this
decision regarding his security he's
also challenging how that original
decision was taken and don't forget
we've also got the phone hacking cases
underway as well at the high quarters
well the most important the most
prominent of those is this full trial at
the moment against mirror group
newspapers but the breaking news today
is that Harry has lost one of his bids
about the security situations he will
not be able to challenge this decision
taken that he cannot pay for his own
policing okay thanks Laura